[Applause]
the sound of pots and pans against the
release of prisoners in Argentina it
resonated in dozens of cities across the
country in the last week's discontent in
Argentina's penitentiary system has been
on the rise kovat 19 has prisoners on
the alert demanding better prison
conditions or house arrest but victims
of those under arrest are afraid of
being victimized for a second time if
some prisoners are released
my sister was raped during a birthday
party right next door he told her to
remain quiet and he'd give him money
then we received a phone call from the
school because my sister was crying
every day now he has been released
Juan Carlos 13 year old sister was raped
by Pedro Olmos
he's 68 year old neighbor almost was
released a week ago because he's
considered to be at risk of Kovach 19
maybe almost family lives right here
next door to the 13 year old girl he
raped last year and even though he's not
serving his house arrest in this
locations neighbors say that he's able
to move around freely and fear for their
safety
even though Wallace is in detention 20
blocks away a few days ago his family
threatened Juan Carlos and his family
they were armed we were talking to local
media and his grandson came out with a
weapon and said he was going to kill us
my sister is afraid he'll come back and
rape her I'd like to tell the judge that
released him what would he do if the
same thing happened to him there are
currently over 90 thousand prisoners in
Argentina they're requesting nonviolent
inmates at risk should be put under
house arrest are they waiting for blood
to be spilled we are human beings isn't
their right to life local media reports
over 2,000 prisoners have been put under
house arrest but Argentina lacks the
resources to control with ankle monitors
they're staying home I understand
coronavirus is affecting the world and
we need to sit new conditions on how to
treat prisoners there are parameters
that cannot be violated we need to
improve
and maybe released those who have been
involved in violent crimes but right now
violent men are out and that's why
thousands of people protested with pots
and pans a message to the judiciary so
their safety won't be at risk terasawa
al Jazeera Buenos Aires